E aí
Oi boa noite
e a fui convidado para falar aqui nesse
evento sobre o amor Exatamente porque
como compositor Esse é o tema
mais presente naquilo que escrevo
acho que talvez mais do que a única
palavra que tem mais do que amor nas
minhas letras R eu que tudo que escrevo
faço do ponto de vista da minha
experiência na verdade quando comecei a
me preparar para esse evento já diante
mão peço desculpas a vocês que Estou
extremamente nervoso porque eu poderia
fazer um show para 10 mil pessoas mais
falar sobre o amor é talvez a coisa mais
difícil porque a
e como definir Lu como a é uma coisa
intangível impalpável subjetiva e na
verdade eu tenho uma ideia de que o amor
se assemelha aquilo que é o desconhecido
é algo que embora possamos
reconhecer dentro da gente
buscamos incessantemente
e no outro no mundo nas coisas então de
certa maneira é aquilo que não temos
portanto é o que é completamente
diferente
eu já assistiu isso a a maneira
como as pessoas mesmo entendem aquilo
que escrevo vou dar um exemplo eu a uma
música minha
chamada para você guardei o amor
que se tornou um grande sucesso mas para
minha surpresa a música uma música muito
tocada
tocada em casamento sim a
os partos na minha filha enfermeira me
contou o pão tá lá na playlist do parto
as pessoas cantam e eu não vou dizer que
não entenda Mas é uma coisa curiosa
porque quando escrevi essa música no dia
que escreveu essa música Menino
Exatamente Essa forma das raras as
músicas que eu escrevi a letra primeiro
e depois fui musica lá porque havia uma
ideia Clara na minha cabeça
evidentemente a partir daquilo que
estava sentindo
bom e quando terminei de escrever eu
falei essa é a música mais triste que
alguma pessoa já poderia ter escrito
é porque a primeira estrofe dela
primeiro quadro assim para você guardei
o amor que nunca soube dar
é o amor que tive e vi sem me deixar
sentir sem conseguir provar sem entregar
e repartir
e eu fico imaginando uma vamos lá uma
noiva
entrando na igreja
para você guardei o amor que nunca soube
dar o amor que tive e vi sem me deixar
sentir sem conseguir provar sem entregar
e repartir é o ato
reconhecimento da incapacidade na na
verdade a música Vai muito a leva ela
claro que é compreensível que ela Tem se
tornado porque a uma forma de
interpretar lá que é isso é um sujeito
desesperadamente em busca dessa
possibilidade de experimentar de receber
então eu sempre imaginei uma criança
nascendo e depois vai saber a mãe
cantando isso não
bom e isso me leva a uma história a
coisa mais dura que eu tenho ouvido na
vida
o que é mais importante aquela que mais
me ensinou uma frase que minha filha eu
tenho cinco filhos
Sofia é a segunda
e
quando junto jovem hoje ela tem 33 anos
mas quando disse não devia ter 15 16 ela
chegou e falou para mim pai
e você que fala tanto sobre o amor o que
você faz com amor dos esquilos os outros
sentem por você
não tá falou essa frase eu fiquei
é
impactado imóvel o que
ela era irrespondível de alguma maneira
a Sofia tava dizendo exatamente que eu
falava falava falava estava
completamente a
é igual especificamente né alto sentado
como muitos artistas sons e eu sei que
só a simplesmente falando do que eu
sinto eu sinto eu amo pois eu quero eu
quero você eu beijo a minha as minhas
como eu acabei de dizer eu falo mais
além da palavra amor a primeira eu e é
natural porque o que a gente como eu
disse é o que eu vivo é aquilo que eu
penso é a forma como eu consigo me
expressar mas na verdade
quando ela me disse isso eu falei alma
competitivo na maneira como eu estou
considerando
a o amor por quê bom então beijo amor
Olá seja justamente
e ficar quieto Abrir
deixar o outro
amar pessoa é
a
reconhecê-la a
identificá-la e não querer mudá-la a sua
sua sua Aos aos seus propósitos né
isso é uma coisa Curiosa porquê
é uma Nós pensamos assim um amor
incondicional pelos filhos na de novo já
falei tenho simples me lembro me lembro
exatamente quando o meu primeiro filho
nasceu Teodoro é muito jovem tinha vive
vim
23 anos
E durante nove meses da gestação aquela
expectativa isso nós com ele nasceu
olhei Funny e agora eu tive a impressão
de que eu não amava e isso me deu assim
uma sensação de absurda
porque falei eu não sei quem é esse
pequeno se não é daí nós temos essa
ideia de que pelos filhos O amor é
incondicional Mas isso é uma coisa que
vai se desenvolvendo o que você vai
criando vínculos laços você vai vendo
ele aí você vai começando a entender que
o que você quer o que você quando se
amam filho incondicionalmente Justamente
não impor condições para que ele a
e não estabelecer aquilo que ele Deva
ser ele não tem que te atender um filho
como um exemplo do que é o grande amor
incondicional ou seja não há nada mais
nobre mais importante ele não tá para te
servir ele tem que estar lá o verdadeiro
amor que eu compreendi cima do pai é
isso
deixá-lo crescer e não não
Aprendendo como se ele tivesse que me
satisfazer
enfim a mas meus filhos cresceram todos
eles estão ali grandes Olha eu escrevi
um monte de coisa eu não tô falando nada
do que eu escrevi eu sinto muito mas
então é isso eu continuo pensando que a
ideia do amor é justamente a é se
ausentar Na verdade uma coisa muito a
a Hípica comum provavelmente todos nós
já tivemos
em determinado momento tem alguém do seu
lado a pessoa que vós quem você ama você
simplesmente
o que caísse bens ou Vila deixá-la ser
porque é exatamente a uma questão
curiosa na praia porque a atração que
nós sentimos pelo por um outra pessoa
provavelmente e a em geral parte de uma
coisa que tenha
afinidade daquilo que reconhecemos como
possível vínculo com o impossível
código de entendimento tanto eu creio
que o que nós buscamos
é exatamente a diferença a
complementaridade aquilo que não temos é
justamente porque tu que chora por uma
pessoa e admira e fala essa pessoa
é eu quero ela na minha vida eu quero
mesmo que eu aqui é você olha e
reconhece
e não reconhece você
e
imagina ia junto daquela pessoa e com
aquela pessoa ao lado daquela pessoa
você poderá sim
fazer coisas e conhecer coisas que você
dentro desse não sabe o que são eu acho
isso é uma engraçada um paradoxo né a
gente quer alguém que
não sei se você já completamente
diferente da gente
e a Justamente por isso porque
Já não basta ser só há uma coisa curiosa
também sobre a
e essa ideia né do Amor Incondicional
eu sou o quarto de cinco filhos uma
família Paulistana e eu sou ladeado por
dois irmãos que tiveram até um meningite
coincidente mente né e cada um deles
desenvolveu a teve comprometimento em
graus diferentes e tudo mais mas quando
me de nasce o meu irmão acima de 65 anos
mais velho ele ficou deficiente auditivo
a e a irmã que nasceu de mim três anos
mais nova ela teve sim o comprometimento
neurológico muito maior e tudo mais e
[Música]
e São pessoas que teve tiveram suas
capacidades digamos
limitadas ou com outro tipo de
desenvolvimento
e
nasce
e tendo eles ao meu lado É sim
consegui ter consciência ou compreensão
melhor dizendo daquilo que
qual era quais eram as suas
peculiaridades as suas características e
as suas limitações no caso ele sempre
foram assim eles eram assim como são
assim e essa
relação com pessoas e meus irmãos amados
que brincava era uma vida Alegre certo
eu lembro a maior melhor brincadeira da
gente tinha um sofá com 3 almofadas de
derrubar vamos as almofadas e a ler os
nossos navios e eu me lembro então de
dia eram
normais sempre foi
e é uma coisa que eu sempre que eu
acredito que a 1 o
que nos faz igual área
o iguais é justamente as diferenças ou
seja as individualidades cada um de nós
não há possibilidade de termos sermos
idênticos estão na melhor coisa que tem
é você olhar
e para o outro enfim eu confesso que
continuo nervoso e tem um pouco de
sensação de estar me enrolando Mas é uma
boa coisa né porque voltando as minhas
canções aquilo que eu falo o que aprendi
também é que não bastam as palavras eu
sou hábil com as palavras quando escrevo
músicas quando faço Sedex no entanto eu
isso é pouco volta a minha filha que
falou que você faz com amor dos outros
que se sentem que os outros sentem por
você
e botou minha canção original para você
guardei amor que é onde eu escrevi o
segundo verso é para você guardei o amor
que sempre quis mostrar
que vive em mim e é o que eu acredito
é verdade vamos tentar concluir de uma
maneira mais palpável e sobre algo que é
o que está acontecendo
e quando você pensar no outro no
ou seja não apenas em você
Oi e
a relação amorosa com o mundo ela tem
que considerar
é aquilo que não apenas me serve o meio
ambiente é coisa para mim é sim a uma
necessidade imperiosa de cuidarmos
daquilo do amor amor pela vida Amor Pela
Terra é o amor pelo lugar onde estamos
vivendo o ar que respiramos aqui todos
nós estamos sabendo não há chance de não
sabemos o desastre que está em curso
e isso é uma maior prova de desamor O
que é o egoísmo eo imediatismo
aquilo que você acha que
só interessa aquilo que me serve por
enquanto tá bom beleza tão de um
frio vocês Curitibanos sabem que aqui
faz muito frio mas fez um frio
completamente despropositado em outros
lugares pegando fogo na Grécia e tudo
mais ou seja
Ah tá bom não está e como estará daqui a
50 anos nós todos aqui tenho filhos
agora netos a eles
bom então é é pensar não apenas essa
atitude amorosa
poderíamos que devemos ter demonstrar
E ai ai é isso eu realmente a imaginaria
falar muito melhor mas talvez da próxima
vez tá precisa exatamente isso
É eu sei cantar
a It's sobre o amor eu busco busco busco
busco as palavras e
elas não são suficientes eu reconheço
dentro de mim um impulso amoroso uma
uma cama me sinto um homem
capaz de amar
é o que o amor mesmo que me transformou
e me podemos
pode me trazer até aqui Agradeço a vocês
Muito obrigado espero ter um
[Música]